Okay, for a
bit hoping to be back here a little
earlier, but I got held up with uh some
cluster maintenance stuff. At least one
of the boxes is back online now. So,
this one is going to be off until I get
an extra cable for it. So, um I think
what we're going to do now is we're
going to do a little bit of stuff on
TTT. We are going
to probably look at VRays and have a
meeting at some point here. I think
those are the two main things I really
want to get today is TTT and B
trace. All
right. Well, I'm just sitting down
here. I got to say that
uh Florida, this time of year, you do
not want to walk outside and open your
mouth. You eat a whole mouth full of
bugs.
soon. Just in time for the new puffer
facility. All right,
TTT. So, this
one. So, I'd like to know where this
graphic came
from. Me find the graphic.
This is how it
joint first and joint second. It's all
right
guys. Yeah, I don't see where this uh
particular graphic came
from. Assuming that this thing is
correct
though, let me just read through it
fresh now and see if I messed anything
up. So,
You initialize task which is K Q and V.
This does not get reset. K QB and extra
get. Then on the forward you make a
learner which we have in it state here
to give you model and optim
right. So you
encode and then
state.train train
token and then this is supposed I think
this is just pseudo code right because
Brad is not a thing. So this is supposed
to be tap
loss gradient with respect to the
model. Do I have the stop grad in the
correct spot?
self.mod.
So inner loop
gradient we make sure these match as
well because we have forward and forward
And they need to be the
same, you know. I think I might have
made I might have broken this
thing.
No, cuz the only thing that has a
gradient here is the uh the model
output, right?
I think that's the only thing that gets
a gradient is the model
output. And either way, the optimizer is
only defined on the model parameters,
right?
So is it that the default learning rate
is too high for the uh for the
optimizer? Could
that's it's this thing
right and they have PyTorch
code which is like massive
We do not recommend training with this
codebase.
I mean, how are they going to write400
lines and then say that this is the slow
word? Okay, this is clearly not just a
TTT layer, right? This is so this is
yeah, TTT lm. This is not just TTT.
I don't know what the heck they're doing
there.
Um, last hidden states and gradients for
PTT layer.
Yeah, this is just insanity. Um, do I
risk looking at the jack
projections. Um, this is not how it's
described here.
whatsoever. I have no idea why it's like
that. And the thing is that the like the
simple pipe which is also not simple.
The thing that annoys me here is I can't
even like see how this is supposed to
work because it's it's too much of a
mess like this here. Okay, so this is
they have
weight and bias
initialized and then they do compute
mini back in
here
xq. Yeah, I don't know how this is
supposed to be premputed either. This
doesn't make sense.
Oh, they're
doing they're not using autograd
here. They're manually computing
gradients. That's why
Okay, maybe I can get something out of
it now.
k. Now the thing I don't understand is
like
already? That's not how this thing
works, right?
Q. Oh, that is totally how this works.
I'm
done. That is totally how this
works. Okay.
then I'm going to have to check those
gradients. Let me at least make this
modification before I
it,
right? So, we look at
And just make sure this isn't the
learning rate
code. I kind of see how they have it
written this way now
because this model breaks autograph. So,
they just didn't use
inputs? Okay, let's read this whole
thing.
batch numbum
heads num mini batch mini batch
size I don't see time
there I do not see
form I have no idea what that
is I have no idea what dual Like I don't
know what they're doing with that.
layer? So, we're not going to be able to
read this because this is not going to
match what they have otherwise. So this
is the normal
trill. I also really can't tell if they
have a time
dimension. I think we ignored this
because I think that this is because
it's like multi head data. This is not
what's described
here. The key here though is they
compute the
gradient with respect to W1 and the
bias.
step token ETA
mini. So we should see what they use for
this parameter, right?
token ETA
mini and then they
store the last
states the last gradient I don't know
what they do with the last gradient
al. So when does this thing get
initialized? This
W1 they have in it here.
Are we going to be able to follow
this TTT
linear? This is the only file. Do they
have a train in
here or is this just
um massive crazy demo?
paper? Okay, let's see.
TT
layer. Oh, D. He got it from
here. Okay.
What is this paper? This is a really
wonky paper that was recently used in
the Nvidia one minute video generation
with the Tom and Jerry clips. Uh it is a
replacement for an LSTM that trains the
hidden state as part of the forward
pass. It's very weird.
I have it implemented and it doesn't do
anything so far.
Okay, let me actually start going
through this slide because I want to
make sure I didn't miss
anything.
Our idea is to use self-supervised
learning to compress the historic
context X1 through XT into a hidden
state
ST by making the context an unlabelled
data set and the state a
model. Concretely, the hidden state ST
is now equivalent to
WT, the weights of a model F, which can
be a linear model, a small neural net or
anything else.
The output rule is
model. Okay.
Output token is just the prediction on
X made by with the updated weights
WT update rule is a is a single step one
step of gradient descent on some
self-supervised loss with rate learning
rate
ADA. Why did that citation take me to
here?
right? They initialized the initial
weights to
Every decide which input to remember or
forget. RW remembers inputs that produce
large
gradients. One choice of L is
reconstructing X itself.
The forward pass of ATT layer has a
corresponding backward pass. Our forward
pass only consists of standard
differentable operators except the
gradient operator.
calling backward on delta L means taking
the gradient of
gradients. Ah shoot. So this is this
actually I might have implemented this
wrong
then TTT layers have the same inference
as RNN
layers and self
attention outer loop parameters areated
by
theta. Hang on. An important difference
between the two nested learning problems
is that the inner loop gradient is taken
with respect to W the parameters of F
while the outer loop gradient is taking
with respect to the parameters of the
rest of the
network. Okay.
Since both W and various datas appear
together in equation
4, we emphasize their difference in
nature. In the inner loop, only W is off
much.
Yes. In the outer loop, theta K, V, and
Q are optimized alongside theta rest.
And W is merely a hidden state, not a
parameter. That's how I implemented it.
The naive TTT layer developed so far is
already efficient in the number of
floating point operations. However, its
update
rule cannot be parallelized because WT
depends on WT minus one in two places
before the minus sign and inside
gradient of L. Yes, since gradient of L
contains the bulk of the computation, we
focus on making this second part
parallel.
Wait. The general update role can be
expressed as this.
The general update rule of GD can be
expressed like that where GT is the
descent direction. Once we have
calculated GT for 1 through
T, we can then obtain all the
WTF through a [ __ ] of the second half of
equation six.
To parallelize gt is 1 through
t, we can take all of them with respect
to w0.
GT, we can take all them with respect to
W0. This variant is known as batch
gradient
descent. Since the sum is the same as
the gradient with respect to
w0 over x1 through t as a
batch that is an incredibly stupid
analog that is not remotely close to
correct.
Okay, I was wondering why I was getting
weirdo messages about this paper that
made absolutely no sense. It's because
the paper makes absolutely no
sense. No, when you're doing like batch
versus mini batch gradient descent,
you're going through different samples
of the same data set that don't depend
on each other. When you're doing a
sequence modeling problem in which the
state directly depends on the previous
state, it's not batch versus mini batch
gradient
descent. If you do it all at once or
not, it's a completely different
algorithm.
for a proposed solution. Mini bath
gradient descent is shown in figure
six. Denote the TTT bath size by B.
Okay, that's not mini B. That's not
how
Oh, this is the
entire entire update. Sure. Whatever.
Hang on, let me make sure I didn't miss
anything. There are two potential
channels for propagate information from
WS to WT or as the less than [ __ ] and the
gradient
operator. The [ __ ] sum is always active,
but the gradient channel is only active
when
WS is from a previous mini.
Okay, it's a really weird little
approximation.
Fine. Yeah, Ryan, it's a stupid They're
describing it really stupidly. They're
drawing an analogy to they like they
made some wacko approximation to like
batch state updates over segments of
time and they drew some like wacko
analogy to mini batch SGD that doesn't
make any bloody sense. That's
all. There's nothing to understand. It's
just
stupid. Like the technique is kind kind
of
okayish.
Um, the description is just stupid.
That's all it is.
I've been reviewing MLM math for
interviews and I can never tell if I'm a
[ __ ] if the math in these papers is
random. You know, the math in these
papers is usually pretty [ __ ] on
average.
Like they clearly just hacked a thing
and then like posttop came up with a
bunch of math to justify it, but if you
actually like read it bit by bit, it's
just like it clearly doesn't make any
bloody
sense. Well, the thing is like I'm going
through enough of these lately that I'm
actually like getting that. So, I'm
getting better and better quickly at
evaluating like which of these is likely
to be [ __ ] or not. So, before I was
going mostly off of
experiments, right? But now I'm also
looking at papers from the math and I'm
seeing whether I think that it's likely
that the technique would be good when
applied ex exhaustively to a bunch of
environments or not as well.
horrendous. This is what I'm doing on my
stream. I streamed 10 hours and 40
minutes to this on
Saturday. We implemented a CUDA kernel
for Brix.
this? Oh, this is just writing out the
gradient. Okay, whatever.
We cannot
compute all
B of the
GTS through a single
M. We need B outer products and comput
them one by one.
fine. Yeah, there's this dual
form. Okay,
whatever. Is there an official an
official definition of a dual form? Is
this even correct use of this term?
Primal
dual. Yeah, I thought this was more
precise.
duel. Okay, this is not actually a dual
form. They're just like adopt using it
because it's like I don't know, we made
a duel to the problem.
This is like peak academic
horit number has nothing to do with the
number of
dimensions. This is literally just
saying look there's an alternative form
of the problem so we're going to call it
a
duel. That's not what a duel is.
I'm not even a math guy at this time.
Okay, so I see what they did. Uh, this
is not even a like this is not a this is
not even the same problem by the way.
This is a efficiency
hack for an approximation of the problem
and a pretty severe one at
that. Let me get the implementation
details to see if there's anything I
missed because this thing just doesn't
work at all right
breakout. Oh, wait. Learnable. Wo.
The initialization WO is shared between
all
sequences even though subsequent weights
are different for each input
sequence.
Oh, and welcome boxing
byes. Subsequent weights are different
for each input sequence. I think I threw
that up royally, didn't I?
Instead of setting W equals Z, we can
learn it as part of the outer
loop. Since outer loop
parameters are always denoted by thetas
instead of
W's, assign alias theta and it equal
W0 significantly improves training
stability.
Learnable learnable learning
rate. Base learning rate is set to one
for TTT linear.
Okay. Um, how does this thing work with
initial weight
zero? So, this is why they they don't
use autograd for this thing. So, we're
not allowed to use autograd.
right? Maybe they don't have a butts.
I could have sworn I saw one in
there. Maybe they describe it as like an
efficiency optimization or like a
there. You see right here that this is
their initialization. We can use
this in TTMLP. No, not TTMLP. We're
doing TT linear right now. TT
linear. Why did they make this a
parameter?
directly bit confus confusing why they
do that.
dim. Presumably this is per example or
something.
Oh, I see. Because this gets like
broadcast expanded or some weird thing.
That's
guess. Are they learning X?
they're learning this this weight matrix
gets learned per example per
trajectory. So you start with this and
then
this these params are learned as the
state. So the state that usually comes
out of the neural net uh like out of an
LSTM they've made this state a
network. It's
weird.
Can I not use Wait, if I do make this a
parameter, I can use autograph,
right? If I can use autograph, it's not
terrible.
without. I'd like to at least not have
the chance of screwing up the autograd
initially because it is learnable,
right? We want this to
be learned.
So I can actually just do this. This is
W0,
right? It's even
easier. And
Wait. So this only gets learned in the
algorith.
Yes. It's got to be It's never the
simple paper. It's never the simple
paper. It's always got to be the most
complicated possible [ __ ]
thing. I guess I did get to do
prioritize replay the other day and that
was pretty easy, huh?
train. Pretty much every single
descriptive piece of this paper sucks.
Like the method's actually pretty novel
and interesting, but the description of
the method, including the pseudo code,
the code, the text, the map, every
single part of it just sucks.
So you give it let's say we're going to
get W in the state, right?
statewt W and then we're going to
get B stateb
anymore. And then this is going to be at
hidden at
W plus
B like this.
Let's add something here so I can
actually freaking Okay.
this. Yeah, there we go. Just needed the
app signs to be highlighted so I can
freaking tell them apart.
I never use
these. Um I guess I could just
whatever. Okay, so now the loss the loss
we can still use this on,
right? So this is model output. We'll
call this
TTT output.
view. And then
[Music]
you you kind of do want an optimizer
with this, don't you?
turn. Okay, we're going to take these
variables. These have to be detached.
It's very tricky because you have to be
tracking which variables get detached or
output
optim you zero the gradient you backward
through
this almost forgot
detached? This is so It's so sketchy. I
think it's technically like
attach.expand
The the thing that's really difficult
about this whole thing, right, is this
is like this is pushing what autograd
was designed for. And you have to be
really really careful about like what is
going to be taken a derivative of versus
not.
silently. Okay.
So hidden at W +
B. This should be the only operation
that has a gradient because and forward
all this is going to get called inside
of for no graph. So this enables
gradient just for this
op you optimize
this and you're should be okay and then
output is just going to
be
hidden at W +
B like this you decode the output and
you're good.
Okay, let's bring this code down to the
train pass and
see if it's hopefully not terrible here
either. Okay, so first of all, this
state
stuff, this goes up here,
right? I guess there's no reason to have
to
We can do
this. Probably cleaner to do
this. Uh we still don't need we don't
need this until we actually do this
move.
Right. So now this has to be
here hidden.
at the m +
v. This goes this is
ttt
output step this gradient or step this
model and
then now this is where I think this the
thing that we just did is uh paid
off. Hidden
at plus. I'm pretty sure that just
works and then you append
yellow. We could just do yellow here
just so we don't screw it up.
probably slightly slower, but it's
probably worth it to not break
it. So now all we have to do is figure
out this new initial state
shenanigans. Does it W be an
state? Oh yeah, it's totally fine
there. I think actually this might be
okay.
state missing batch size. Okay, it's
fine. I did forget that.
Uh, do I
know do I know the batch
size or pass batch That's
Oh, I see how we can even paralyze this
nicely. Okay, I see how we're going to
be able to do this as
That's
in backwards
224 seriously break autograph.
I mean, we don't technically need it,
right? What's the gradient of
this? It's like it's something super
basic, right? It's like the weight
matrix or know the input, I
think. See how they do this?
two. Yeah. Gradient with respect to
weight should just be hidden.
Oh yeah, you have to you do multiply by
the difference,
Can you seriously not just autograph
this
thing? Like even if I do it here, it's
going to make it such a pain in the ass
to try the other version of it, right?
Because like if I want to swap this into
an MLP, I'm like writing my own freaking
autograd again. Like what do I need to
for? I'm writing my own autograd,
right? It's like I've done it before.
It's not fun.
Let me see if there's like a way around
this.
Okay, so this is just not picking up
that there's been any optimization
whatsoever. Let me
see. Hidden at W + B.
and probably just do this. Maybe clone
keeps grab
How do I keep required Brad but detach
the earlier
right and then it becomes deeply unhappy
with me.
Okay, that's better. Now we just have
some shape mismatch shenanigans,
Oh, we get to get rid of the stupid app
symbol syntax,
Okay. So, we uh apply that to the
backwards and
hopefully we can kind of do
Okay. So, we do hidden unsqueeze two
here.
This should just be hidden as zero,
isn't it? Or up t. I mean, it's one step
at a time.
This needs to be
unsqueeze
three. Actually, I think we should just
do it this way,
right?
Oh, because you have
it, dummy.
Yeah. A lot of um honestly like a lot of
my first few years in ML was just
getting really really comfortable
screwing around with tensors.
So, um, yeah, we're going to have some
issues here with this
Okay. So, that actually
works. And then I'm assuming that it
fails the
second. Yep. So,
I think that's it. To be honest, I'm not
sure
place.
No, can't have nice things today.
Okay.
Torch.
Okay. Let's see how it
tttw and they only get
modified by the optimizer,
this like this should be the first
gradient creating
Heck, it actually shouldn't even be a
problem.
Oh, also what the heck are you doing
with your bias
here? The bias should not be index label
t like that. Hang
on. Yeah, the bias should not
be indexed with T.
1281. Yeah. So, I don't know what the
heck happened
there, but this does not get indexed
with
T. It's only a hidden index with T.
fine. Oh, you know what it probably
is? It's probably
this this computation here,
right? I don't find any loss over this
thing though, do I?
Hang on. How does this work? Because I
don't define a loss over this. So, it
shouldn't have a gradient, right? Or is
torch not work that
help. So this is already with just this
saying that I'm doing a double
This variable gets
redefined. So this only depends on
W
hidden
B. This is detached.
It's got to be trying to back prop
through multiple steps of this for some
reason,
right? I would have thought that just
detaching it
copying. Return tensor shares the same
storage with the original one.
So that probably is just not getting set
in the optimizer one,
right? But the detach underscore should
have done
it. Maybe you're not supposed to use
that.
I would think that this is correct to be
honest. Like
this this seems like that could work to
detach the
breath, but it doesn't
Is there anything else this could
be? Oh, I'm probably back propagating
through hidden here,
right? Yeah, I'm probably back
propagating through
hidden. Yeah, that's that's not me.
Ten. This is what I mean when I say you
have to be so so careful with this
method. Yep. So now it doesn't break
anymore.
We'll see if when I do this it
breaks because now what you do
um this one you detach here
right now it's wd detach
This is
like ridiculously
ridiculously careful. Like this is like
the autograd's honestly hurting you
here. I see why they just did it without
autograd. The autograd just hurts you.
But the problem is like if you do it
without the autograd like the MLP
implementation is just going to
suck. Single linear is kind of
fine. But yeah the problem of not using
auto right is you don't have auto
encoder. That seems a weird place to
fail.
Wait, why is that here? That should not
be
there. Just an
Lovely. Do you need this uh these W
patches or not. You might not need
these.
Okay, then this should be on the main
train backwards,
right? Yeah. Lost
backwards. So, this is new
hidden stack.
um, maybe I'm doing this part
wrong.
Here use the detached
hidden and the trainable forms of
W. And here you use the hidden and then
the detached
forms of W and B. Right?
do a pattern together of
Yeah. Here.
Bot. Does it expect both of these things
to be differentiable or
something? Okay, we're going to try I'm
pretty sure the original is the correct
operation, but we are going to try this
for the hell of it.
It's not going to work, I don't
think. I mean, we can try this though.
I guess it's the W's that it's like
annoyed. The W's are being modified,
right? Yeah, the W's are being modified.
right? Oh
yeah. Take anomaly detection off. See if
that does
This
learns a little
bit. Let's just uh track
it as we'll put it on
We can go put this to 80 mil as
well. I added a
zero. Okay, put that to 80 mil. Let me
use your bathroom real quick. I'll be
right back. We're going to run some
experiments on this and then maybe we'll
do V trace. Maybe we'll do some other
stuff. I'll be back.
um, that doesn't look amazing.
I think I'm going to go chat with this
guy about this method real quick and uh
and then I'll be back shortly and then
we'll work on VRays.
So me do
that.
Okay. So uh for folks for folks watching
there'll be more back pretty soon. Um
all my stuff is here. This will be open
sourced if it's useful as
well. So if you want to support my work
for free, puffer.ai, start the GitHub.
We're trying to get to 2K. Other than
that, you can get involved with dev or
just chat with the community on the
Discord here. And you can follow me on X
for more RL content. Thanks.